all right
here we go
once again
welcome
all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome to
another episode
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] the voice sounds good today [ __ ]
feeling it
[Music]
anyway
welcome to ripping with griffin y'all i
uh let's see i went to
canada
so i'm going to talk about the canada
trip some funny [ __ ] happened there i
want to talk about
what everybody keeps asking me about
king of the sting i'm gonna give you my
thoughts on cats and all that's going on
severance the nba but welcome to real
food
[Music]
all right y'all golden pipes is back in
the business welcome to roofing with
griffin
welcome to river rocker bad
um
let's see hit the like subscribes
thank you for your subscriptions as
always i love all you subscribers so
keep doing that i do appreciate that and
as you know i'm always on twitch
so catch me on twitch eric griffin
gaming on twitch
i usually do that right after
this
but i do it most days to check that out
and also make sure
you know i have to do i need to do some
catch-up videos on this but i'm also
doing some
patreon content so make sure you check
me out on my patreon eric griffin if you
want to get extra bonus stuff and i
might talk about specific shows so shout
out to all the patreon members and
youtube members because if you're a
youtube member i also have those videos
private for youtube i actually might
open up some of the
after this episode i'm gonna open up
for everybody the two that i already did
so you can see kind of what goes on i
mean sometimes it's weird because i did
one video where my couch was being
delivered and in the middle of the video
i had to like get on the phone and all
this kind of stuff but that's what
happens it's more personal and intimate
into my life so
damn it i was trying not to cough this
episode but again welcome to uh riffing
with griffin and you know all that all
that great stuff so
hey first i want to address some stuff
before i get into the meat of the thing
it's like i want to thank like all the
people that are sending me messages i
get these weird messages about like
they're like yo griff are you okay
because when you're on your podcast you
make all these noises and the breathing
i just want to let everybody know i have
a sinus condition and i've always had a
sinus condition and around this time of
year the sinus condition kicks in even
more than it normally does and i got
covid in christmas and new year's and i
think i had lingering effects of that
that was just affecting my voice and i
was messing me up on stage and
everything but i'm i'm slowly starting
to feel better so you know that that's
what that's about and also i'm allergic
to something in my office i know that's
what it is like i gotta vacuum the floor
i'm i'm really messy so i gotta like do
that and i think that's gonna clear up
all that stuff so i hear your messages
out there like some people think they're
doctors so they'll hit me up and be like
i'm super concerned about these noises
that you're making you know what i mean
so i like i sort of appreciate it but
it's still like a veil fat joke
you know
we're just kind of like come on man so
that that goes out there to all you
people so thanks for the concern and all
that stuff but i'm just letting you know
that i'm starting to feel better you can
even tell by my intro singing i know
when i'm my voice is like getting back
to where it should be but it's you know
it takes some time and you know i'm not
getting any younger
so you know i'm working on that
so speaking of okay and then okay let's
let me what should i talk about okay so
i went to canada all right so again you
all know how i feel about going to
canada you have to get this stupid pcr
test and all these stupid things but
apparently they're opening that all up
apparently they're taking all that away
too so now you can get in and out of
canada i think
at the very minimum you have to be
vaccinated i think that's going to be
the thing i think they're going to get
it down to that um and who even knows
too much they might release all that but
and i actually think that the whole
wearing a mask on an airplane that's
going to go away too in march
um just for something the pilot said on
the plane you know he he came on it was
like please wear your mask and you know
we don't have to want to do paperwork
and all this stuff and
hopefully you know he said he gave the
date he was like march 18th i think it's
all going to be over so i was like oh
man so that's going to be cool um so you
know still you had to pay all this stuff
it was ridiculous because first i did a
college gig and shout out to uh what
what what college did i go to i forgot
what college i went to already man my
memory is just going but i went to a
college in mexican michigan so i had to
go back to grand rapids
excuse me yeah so i went to grand rapids
and i was at uh ferris state so shout
out to ferris state it was a really
small show in a big theater and they had
to wear masks it was their restrictions
are like so i you know i get why
like some if you're a college student
and they're like hey come to the show
uh you want to come to the show uh but
you have to wear a mask uh i i think i
would be like yeah especially if you're
not a real fan of mine you don't really
know me be like who's that guy i don't
want to wear a mask and watch that so i
told i think they're going to relift all
these restrictions all over the country
so we'll see how that goes man you know
because right now you know i don't think
people know that that's going on too
because my buddy vinnie's telling me a
story how he was in the store
you know because now they lifted it in
california too in los angeles county too
you don't have to wear masking doors but
people are still like you know coming up
to you with their caring stuff like hey
you need to put your mask on you know
and just like yo uh you need to read the
news and mind your damn business you
know what i mean i don't like that don't
walk up to me with that like just wear
your mask and stay away from me if
you're so worried you know what i mean
so hopefully that news will get out and
people will stop getting in and all that
so i went to so so i had to go to
michigan grand rapids uh to go to ferris
state so and then i had to get a covet
test in michigan to get on the plane to
go to uh
canada man so i had to drive around i
had to get this i was in the dumbest
rental car like it was so small and then
i found a spot i found a spot and then
like here was the trick let me give you
like a little trick
i don't know if this works everywhere
but so i go up i roll up to the place
and you know you have to like register
online but i needed to ask the guy first
i was like yo before i do this online
because there was nobody in line so i
was like um
i was like uh is this for travel you
know and he was like yeah and i was like
can i get it i needed to get it by
tomorrow because i was leaving tomorrow
you know he was like yeah you'll get it
tomorrow and then it was like i was like
how much is it he was like he was like
well if you select yes on the first
question you don't have to pay so i was
like what so i look and the first
question is have you been around someone
with covid in the past
you know in you know in or like in the
past 14 days or something like that or
do you think you've been around someone
with covet and if you say yes to that
they'll do the test for free
i was like what so y'all need if you out
there need to take a cover test for
travel you need to depending on where
you go depending on what service it is
you need to like
find that out
that might be a workaround for this
racket that they're doing paying things
so i got mykova test go to canada i was
at this new club it's not even a club
yet it's run by this great dude jack
jake i'm sorry jake jake this great guy
jake he uh uh he was an ex-cop
um you know when he and he got into the
comedy business you know
he's a cool dude and he's trying to run
he runs a bunch of shows in calgary and
all over the place and this is his new
like he wants this to be like a club
location so it was a cool show but the
people aren't comedy trained the lights
were a little weird the sound was a
little weird the bouncer the bouncer was
this sort of
weird dude that he i started talking
about him and i could tell he was like
what like he's never been to a comedy
show and he's never been talked about
before so it was a little weird but he
came around you know and uh but the
shows were weird and i had like a couple
of situations
like one of the shows there was these
three
white boys sitting in the front row and
they were like
you know
drunk okay but like and they were being
obnoxious so my whole show
it's that kind of drunk where everything
i say somebody gotta one of them's gotta
be like yeah or like you know he's
trying to like get me interacting with
him and so i ignored him the whole show
usually you do that like if you're at a
comedy show and you say something out
loud and the comic don't respond trust
me the comic heard you he just don't
want to engage with you because there's
a goddamn show going on okay that's a
show so i did that like seven eight
times where i just ignored them at the
end of the show though i addressed it i
was like yo and then they kept going
like it was like to the point where
it's to the point where it was like this
kind of thing like yeah shut the [ __ ] up
why are y'all talking he's like we're
not talking
we're enjoying you it's that kind of
like nonsensical
nonsensical stuff man and so then the
guy sends me an instagram message oh i
should have put the message up i should
have got the message ready to show you
guys
oh man i don't even know i have so many
messages i don't even know if i can find
i don't even know if i can find this
particular oh here it is perfect ah yes
so he sends me this message and he's
like you kicked me and my friends out
last night that was ridiculous we
weren't even that loud that's what he
said
we weren't even
that loud
like so i wrote him back i was like are
you kidding me you're not supposed to be
any loud you know what i mean like the
dude admitted he was being loud but then
it gets even better he writes me back
bro how am i supposed to figure out what
drink my friend wanted tell telepath
telepathy you know we were really
enjoying your set
so i sent him like a you're the worst
emoji
and then he then he writes me back again
and he says i do apologize
absolutely huge fan we were in tears
right before we had to leave true story
i know they weren't in tears because
they were back there like all angry they
had to like force them to leave and pay
their bills but the point is
it's just one of these like you know
they're not comedy trained yet in
calgary in that location for people to
come to understand like how a show works
but that's just an example of like you
know
you know interacting with your fans on
social media whether it be good or bad
and like actually i feel like that one
worked out like i think these guys are
still fans and you know what i mean i
just had to call them out you know and
so
so that was that was that and then there
was this and thanks for the super chats
guys this is also live we're live on uh
uh youtube right now so if you're
listening uh you know on your app
podcast or
google music or wherever you're
listening to your podcast you know i i
do these live most of the time now
unless i have a guest but you know so
thank you and so if you hear me like
stop in the middle of it am i
interacting so here we are so so that
was that
so
that leads me to the next thing i want
to talk about which is
i like social media so let me tell you
one of the biggest comments i get from
people
when i say if i mention like oh this
troll or i got this negative thing
people say this
literally 95 of the time
hey man don't read the comments that's
what they say
don't read the comments i want to
address this
i love i love social media i like being
on it i like putting up funny things and
then seeing people's reaction and most
of it is overwhelmingly positive because
if you're following me it's because i
would think you're a fan of me so we
have like a shared experience i love
that stuff i actually like reading
comments from people who are like you
know
most of the time is good or they're
asking me a question or like maybe we
have a good back and forth so here's the
thing though
you're telling me don't read the
comments so what you're saying is then
don't be on your social media and there
are people that are like that brendan
shobs like that brendan he has somebody
look at his social media he just put
some posts and then he don't deal with
it
that's
how people are i asked rogan about this
when i first started doing the podcast i
i hit him up i was like joe like
how do you deal with the negative
comments do you ever read or he goes i
don't listen to the negative or the
positive because the positive can send
you in a direction you don't want to be
in either that you think oh everything's
fun and dandy so i don't look at those
and i don't look at the negative ones so
there are people who like that and i
respect that position i'm not like that
i actually like looking at my social
media so that being said
dude people aren't labeling their
comment shitty troll
it's not like there's a it's not like
before you put a comment you get to pick
i'm being mean and disrespectful and
rude and then oh so then a notification
comes up to me this might be a rude
comment do you want to read it that's
not what happens
so
it sucks because
no matter how many positive comments you
get and you're in that good feeling
there's so many really rude
disrespectful troll ass idiots out there
there's some in the chat right now it
just is what it is that's the part of
social media that you have to deal with
so it's not easy man i'm a human being
you know what i mean i got feelings and
stuff too and these people just they
just don't care like the whole point of
it is they're trying to hurt your
feelings or they're trying to whatever
their whatever their motivation is so
those are the part of the things you
have to deal with so i guess i'm
basically saying just please stop
telling me to not read the comments
because there's no way to filter that
until you read it so what i end up doing
is especially on instagram
you send me some troll [ __ ] that's out
of pocket
i don't block anyone by the way unless
they're being like like legit racist
unless they're being legit racist or
they're saying something that's so out
of pocket like like it's so like you go
wow this person is disturbing like maybe
it's a violent threat or whatever you
know you block those people but most of
the time i get one comment from you that
i'm like oh this dude's not a fan and
he's being a [ __ ]
uh
i remove you as a follower if you're a
follower i hide my story from you and i
put you on a restrict
when you get to restrict now i never see
your [ __ ]
if somebody sends me a message that has
been i've restricted them in the past as
soon as i see restrict i just delete it
i don't even open it i don't even look
at it i never hear from them again
but the beauty of that is the reason why
i do that and it's extra work for me you
say why not just block is because
i don't want to silence their voice
you know what i mean like i want i want
those people out there to think
the the the message is still getting out
there so they can you know i'm doing it
for them so they can still feel
something in their in their in
themselves they feel you know you know
how trolls are they're like
you got him bro i got him i want them to
still feel that
i'm giving you that you know and they
can still comment like they can still
write you know and and and here's
another one i get to it's like they'll
be like a troll hit me up and be like oh
man oh i see you've restricted your
comments
no i just have it set for you have to
follow me
to comment that's all it's such an easy
step
so and so but people think like you know
so it's like it's crazy out there so
that's just uh
it is what it is
okay so now let's get to what i'm sure a
lot of you want me to address and talk
about so let us do that now
okay
let's talk about it
good old king and a sting
theo
and brendan my good friends
okay
king and distinct so let's talk about
king and sting and the reason why i'm
talking about this right now is because
i'm start my inbox is flooded
you know hey
are you are you not on kingston anymore
did you get kicked off king of this
thing what's going on with king disting
you know it's just all these um
you know you know what i mean it's all
these comments so i said you know what
let me address it i feel like these
[ __ ] should have addressed it
but i'm gonna address it okay because
this is about me and my fans all right
so let's talk about king and the sting
all right so they were doing king of the
sting and it's called king of the sting
that's brendan and theo they never
changed the name it was king and the
sting okay so the world went crazy y'all
coveted hit
um
our business went went
went away basically in terms of like
touring comedian stuff
so some people decided to move you know
joe rogan moved to austin theo decided
to move to tennessee he moved to
tennessee and he he still lives there so
you know and it's widely known
he talks about it they talk about it on
their podcast on his own podcast you
know he got his own personal issues that
he was dealing with and he was dealing
with these things the whole time so
they still wanted to do their podcast so
they asked steve to come on the podcast
and then i did it a couple times and
then they approached me like yo man we
like this what you're bringing to the
podcast can you just come
it was no like set like hey come this
amount of times at that amount of times
it was like hey can you come and like
be a host with us when theo's not there
and then he'll be like zoomed sometimes
maybe he will be there and we just
started doing it like that and it just
happened like that so then
i'm there i'm i'm you as you know i'm
there hosting sometimes i'm sitting in
one seat sometimes on the couch you know
they trying to figure that out it's
theo's show he can do whatever he wants
he didn't want to sit in that seat he
wanted he was like i kind of like this
energy so you know and he's was dealing
with whatever he was dealing with so he
was in and out in and out and so
we went for months doing it like that
so then they invited chris to come on
the show
uh with us
and then the whole dynamic change
because it was like you know you're
talking about chris is a big huge
personality so is theo so is brendan so
am i really so that so they're uh that
dynamic changed and the numbers were
like huge
so they saw something they were like wow
this is really uh really popular amongst
the defense negative or positive
it got a lot of views it got a lot of
attention
so
they decided
that they wanted to try a new format
king sting and the wing
that's not king sting and eric it was
never king and a sting and eric
it was king and sting and then they now
they decided hey let's do king sting in
a wing and also let's put it on patreon
because y'all don't know how it is with
these podcasts when you're like a slave
to like the ad people you know when the
ad people want you to do this they want
you to do that they want you to do it
this way and that way and they want you
know they're like hey you know it's like
sometimes when you go to patreon that's
direct to fans for the fans
they're putting on great content for you
so like you know you know what i mean
like is it that much is that ridiculous
to be like yo can you pay for this and i
think that people that pay for patreon
you appreciate that you pay for cable
you know you pay to go to basketball
games you pay to go to shows you pay
netflix you pay hulu you pay disney plus
you pay all the streaming services so
this is the same kind of thing it's a
you know weekly content and sometimes
even more so you you're saying hey i
appreciate what you do that's what that
is so they're like you know what instead
of doing like four episodes
of
uh you know where we have to do ads and
all that stuff all the time let's give
them some patreon content of the new
format which is king sting and the wing
chris brendan
and um theo
so
what's happening right now is
they're establishing that
they're showing you what king sting and
the wing is going to look like
it doesn't mean i'm off the show
they've already told me they all have to
talk to me about it like it's like yeah
there's going to be a date you know it
might be twice a month on the other
shows that they're regular doing you
know and some of them still might have
to go out of town whatever it is like
that i'm still a part of the show i'm
just not on the show right now because
they're establishing for you this is the
format king sting and the wing that's
what they're doing
so
you know
so when people keep asking me all these
questions that i get on my inbox all the
time hey man love you on the show or or
even the negative ones who are like you
don't belong on the show like all those
people
everybody's telling me and i go all
right then you know this is it guys
that's my understanding of what's
happening all right
so
and check this out you miss me you're a
fan of me
here i am riffing with griffin so if
you're a fan if you like what the energy
i bring if you like that kind of stuff
and you miss it each week you know
subscribe hit me up
be a part of the riffing with griffin
movement because this is it right here
this is how i'm doing it and don't be
and then also i also am still doing my
other podcast gen the gen we just took
some time off because we we had to
switch studios we switched we had to
switch the people that make our podcast
so we we're getting that all set up
right now and then the holidays hitting
all that stuff but i'm still coming back
with that but guys you can see me here
you're a fan of me watch me right here
weekly riffing with griffin i'm right
here for you you know and if you want me
to do like some of the stuff that they
do let's do it send me some videos you
know you want to send me some some send
me some riffing in the wild
whatever you want to call it we'll call
it our own thing you know what i'm
saying and we'll do it right here so
thank you for the support thank you for
all the people that have been sending me
constant messages every single day about
this
that's it right there it's not as
complicated as you think it is it's not
as like devious there's no ill intent
there's nothing bad going on in the
background guys they just establishing
their new thing and i will be back uh
when when when they're not doing that
when it's like the regular king in this
thing that's free on youtube and free on
what you call it all right so relax and
enjoy it i just did shows with brendan
and chris in the past weekend i talked
to chris all the time check out more
chris on youtube he's doing his uh he's
got another channel called more chris
and and he did some behind the scenes
footage of uh such a brilliant improv
with brendan and some other other people
that were on the show chappelle lacy was
there so you know what i mean like guys
it's not there's no nefarious thing
going on it's just this is the this is
how they you just how you do business
you know you're when you establish
something new you have to show the
product so this is what they're doing
right now so
it is what it is but like i say again if
you missing you some eric griffin
i'm right here
with griffin
all right
so i hope that that
i really hope that that you know you
guys
understand what's going on okay
so that's what that is
okay
okay
um
on my patreon i'll do some q a about it
if you want you know so we'll do that
all right all right next up we're done
with that guys that part of the
discussion is over i addressed it and
that's how it's gonna happen okay so
next up ladies and gentlemen let's talk
about
the
nba
nba talk time y'all i just got now i
addressed this
um last week i was talking about the
trades between the nets and the sixers
um
next and the sixers i talked i talked
about that so now i just want to talk
about what it looks like now and who won
the trade
um
first i feel like for this year
with 20 um 20
uh games left in
the the play in the regular season with
20 games left in the regular season i
think the sixers so far won this trade
first two games that they played against
the knicks and the minnesota
timberwolves
james harden and and joe joel embiid
look
dominant with each other they do once
again james harden does this thing where
you think he's done he can't play and
then he goes to a new place and he's all
of a sudden he sheds 10 15 pounds and
the dude is out here balling because he
looks great triple doubles i think that
this system is perfectly set up for him
you got a dude and joe lane embiid who
is like a generational talent that had
we've never seen a big man this skilled
like this skilled
this many a
accompaniment of skills okay you talking
about the dude can post
the duke mid-range game and the dude can
shoot threes the dude can dribble he's
like seven foot he's big he's dominant
it is
unbelievable
what joel embiid is doing you may have
other players in history who are better
at things than he is like is shaq more
dominant in the post than joel embiid
for sure if they were playing at the
same time shaq would have he's just he
was big strong of freaking nature
but shaq couldn't do the things that
joel embiid can do like it's more
all-around game so it makes it dynamic
you know and then you combine that with
a dude like james harden
and you got some shooters dude now joel
embiid is like
you can't just triple down on him and
then you gotta watch the pick and roll
how him and james harden are running
that pick and roll they go they go
excuse me they're gonna be deadly man
they're gonna be deadly let's look at
the standings right now
uh
where are we at let's look at the
standings right now so the standings as
it stands right now you know you got the
heat who are bawling but this look at
the what the east man the east don't
look scary nothing scary about the east
right now you got the heat bulls 76ers
cavaliers
bucks celtics raptors and then the nets
are in eighth spot right
so
and then here's the thing too man
if the nets play the raptors
in the playing game
playing tournament
kyrie irving's not gonna be able to play
so you know
who knows with that but i just think
that as of right now i feel like the
76ers one to trade we're in the
honeymoon phase right now but this is a
good it's going to be a good 20
game sample size to see
how these guys play
with each other
how they
you know can they can they carry this
team and keep that energy in throughout
the playoffs because i think the east is
wide open and i just don't know a team
that can handle them now of course on
paper you want to see the nets
play
but i don't think ben simmons is going
to play when is he going to play
is kevin durant healthy when is he going
to come back i think they're so scared
of the amount of money they invested in
kevin durant that they're like let's
hold him until we know let's make sure
he's healthy and then let's see what
happens but like they got to get him in
so he can get some reps because that's
how you get hurt like not playing for a
while and then you put this guy in and
then he like overexerts himself or
something happens so i hope that he's
you know basketball game ready so we
could see because i want to see that
team i want to see kyrie
i hope they lift those stupid mandates
too it's so dumb that kyrie irving can't
play home games but if you're
unvaccinated on a visiting team you can
play that's just stupid it's stupid so
hopefully they they get rid of that the
country just completely opens up and we
just move forward with life so hope i
want to see kyrie
and
kevin durant play and ben simmons let's
see what that looks like it looks pretty
dominant i'm on record as already saying
i think last week i said this and i'ma
say it again
i don't think kevin durant is ever going
to be the same
i think that he's
going to continue to be injury prone
i think that like i don't know if he's
ever going to be 100
no one has ever come back from that
injury that he got a torn achilles and
been the same
and it it looks as if his body is giving
out on him or you know because look
playing in the nba is obviously super
tough i don't know if you've ever played
a like have you ever played just a
regular basketball game with your with
your buddies out there
that [ __ ] is taxing you know when you
finish you're like woof and imagine now
you got to do it again the next day and
then the next day and the next day man
you got to be in tip-top
shape it's not easy look at someone like
uh what's to do from the lakers anthony
davis anthony davis is a big huge freak
of nature he always gets hurt
because it's tough to play basketball so
i just feel like
kevin durant
i don't know i want him to i want him to
come back and be like a play 82
and play in the playoffs win the
championship because that will solidify
his career and he'll no one will ever be
able to say well you only won when you
were with the the super team you know
what i mean he'll be able to be like i
went someplace else and i was the leader
but if he can't do that
okay if he if he don't do and i just
he's already missed what 19 20 games
last year he missed a bunch of games
i think he was tired in the playoffs
you could see it was like because they
don't they had no bench i think steve
steve nash i think is such a rookie
coach he don't know how to like manage
minutes
so he let these stars run him run him
over like yeah i'm going to stay in the
game i think that was a mistake that's
why they lost that buck series in my
opinion so
i just don't think kevin durant from the
looks of it this is gonna be him this is
what i think the nets should do
next year
they should trade kevin durant
while
everybody thinks he's still kevin durant
that's what i would do i would get up
trade him someplace get a haul for him
get another star back you know you know
you know what i mean just just so you
don't have to worry about is he a
hundred percent is he gonna ever be that
guy again so you won't have to worry
about it you know but knock on wood
he's still good enough to
you know
be the player that he is
play a majority of the games
and give us the entertainment that he
does because he's a phenomenal all-world
talent but again i just don't think
kevin durant
i just don't think he's ever gonna be
the same player
it just
something seems off it it feels funky to
me you know it feels it feels you know
they like this is now three seasons in a
row
that
you know you know the season you know he
was already like freaking injured so you
count the season that he was with uh
golden state and he injured himself
towards achilles alright so he was
already injured then he came back from
an injury toward the achilles and then
it was like you know covet
bubble he didn't play none of that he
signs with the nets he doesn't play he
doesn't play he doesn't play and then he
comes back
uh you know
uh kyrie hervin gets hurt
kevin durant has to do the bulk of the
things felt like he was tired in those
later games in uh milwaukee and it was
like you know could have won the series
if his toe was smaller
but i just i feel like that was bad
clock i feel not clock management but
bad like minutes management i think they
should have like rested him
find somebody to come in off the bench
and give him some rest so he's like a
hundred percent in the fourth quarter or
in the overtime you know what i mean
but anyways
yeah i know some of you think i'm crazy
i don't think it's wild at all man i see
somebody in the chat saying trading kd
is wild not at all okay what if
follow me here
they know okay like the nets no they
they're they got the doctors they're
there they're behind the scenes like is
this dude like are we getting our return
on investment
that's all i'm saying the dude's making
a lot of money
and all i'm saying is like is he is he
going to be the same player if if they
feel like if the nets management and the
doctors if they feel like if they what
if the doctors went to the management
like yo
it's it's iffy on him uh you know if he
stays in shape or if uh but there's a
chance this could keep happening he
could keep getting injured
why not trade him
why not trade him
you know because because there's a team
out there
you you'll get
whatever you want for the dude man
you know
i don't know that's just my thoughts
you don't got to agree with me
you know what i mean but it is what it
is
you know i you know and see i know y'all
i see all this stuff you're saying like
what is the purpose
of playing like he's on a trajectory to
try to win an nba championship right
that's what you think the nets want and
that's did all this trading they traded
all their picks and everything to get
james harden so now that all that went
to [ __ ] it didn't work and so then they
had to now they traded for ben simmons
they basically have no they it is like
they have to do this now or never
the dude's not young either like how old
is kd i think he's like 33 or something
like that you know what i mean like
somebody google it you know i don't know
how you know how old somebody i just
google it how old is kevin durant
he's 33.
kevin durant's 33 years old man 33. how
many more years do you think he has left
with that injured body being
kevin durant
i don't know man
i don't know
i mean you know maybe you send them to a
team they got like you know
like a couple of young stars and you
know you you you see what's uh what's
going on you know what i mean so i don't
know i mean i don't i don't think it's
so crazy if you it depends on what you
get back right you know but i'm saying
if they did that that would be a trigger
to me to be like oh something's up with
him they know something we don't know
you know what i mean so
33 is not young in the nba
you know what i mean so
so here's the so here's a good example
guys you see the chat so i'm enjoying
the chat we're going back and forth
people are trying to be you know they
say hey i wouldn't do that griff they're
trying to be nice and then you have this
one idiot who said shut up
fatso this is the kind of stuff that you
guys don't have to deal with
like
here's a dude
who looks like
if a cowboy
[ __ ] a troll
and that's what he would look like in
his little picture you know the dude got
on a cowboy hat
you know what i mean like he looked dumb
as [ __ ] and so
i have to like deal with people like
that on my thing all the time
imagine you having to deal with that all
the time you know
so
it
it's
it's bananas
you know what i mean it's like it's it's
bananas like that you guys think that
it's so so like
this is a good example of what i was
talking about earlier here we are
chatting and i'm reading the chat i'm
enjoying the chat and then somebody
dropped that in there but you [ __ ]
wanted to say to me hey bro just don't
read the chat
well
what do you want you want me to interact
with you and then you you know you have
those you know so i'm just using that
normally i just ignore it but i'm just
trying to show you guys
that that that's the kind of thing that
drops in in the middle of it that was
like a great timing
for that idiot to do that you know whose
mother obviously you know
[ __ ] uh like a like
shrek in a cowboy hat and
had him [ __ ] him out her [ __ ] and
here he is you know what i mean so
you know what i mean it like it like is
what it is you know and then by the way
youtube itself
kind of like when they see cursing or
certain things they put like a show or
hide on there so then sometimes
i can um
you know i can like decide if i if i
want to show it or not you know what i
mean so it just it depends on that you
know
anyways
i'm not going to read any other i just
wanted to read that one just to point
out
that that's the kind of stuff that goes
on in
my world but anyways going back to it uh
you know i'm not i'm i'm just throwing
out some options you know i i i
personally that's what i'm saying i
would consider trading kevin durant
just to get you know because if you if
you're gonna roll with kyrie irving the
dude's good too he won a championship
with one other star already you know
what i mean the dude was like hit a huge
three in the game so you know you want
to go with that guy who's super talented
younger
you know then maybe you get another star
who knows if not let's just knock let's
say knock on wood that kevin durant can
stay relatively healthy for a season
and not get injured and miss so many
games and then
lead them in the playoffs because let's
be 100 again last year
they were beating milwaukee's ass
okay
we all know
that that championship last year is a
joke
and you know what
if you i'm gonna i've talked about this
before but since we're on an nba rant
um
let me see last eight
nba champs let me see if you can if we
can uh
uh get a list like that ah perfect i
love it
i love wait come on oh here we go this
is perfect i love that this happened
guys
here's the thing about the nba dude
oh this is perfect too i can like wait
let me oh yeah yeah let me do this let
me do this let me just so you guys can
see so we can go over this together
uh where is that screencap all right
boom all right look at this guys when
you look at this list of nba champions
there is
not an asterisk but there's a thing you
can point to to be like this is why that
team won
there's some nonsense that has happened
in the last
freaking
one two three like in the la
other than
the
the last legit nba champion to me on
this list was the san antonio spurs in
2014.
that was the last legit this team is
fully healthy or relatively and this
team's fully healthy and they battled
and this team won
san antonio spurs was the last one all
right 2015 golden state warriors win
kyrie irving
and kevin love get injured in the
championship
lebron james still takes them to six
games
and they lose
there isn't a person who doesn't feel
like with kyrie and kevin love they beat
the golden state warriors and if they
would have beat the golden state
warriors
i don't think the warriors would have
had the confidence to continue to do
what they did it might have derailed
them who knows the whole history of the
nba could have been changed at that
point so that championship was like
next year cleveland they come back from
3-1
they're down 3-1
draymond green gets a technical
and he gets thrown out of the next game
cleveland
goes on to win
that one's uh
because like that one's a but it's still
there's a feeling that if draymond green
was playing in that game they would have
beat cleveland 4-1 that's the feeling
that's out there all right then kevin
durant goes to
kevin durant goes to the warriors it's a
wrap
it's a wrap
73 win team
adds a all world top five all-time
scoring talent like kevin durant no one
was going to beat them that's an
asterisk in our mind that's one of those
where we go
boom boom
this is not this is just we felt like
that was nonsense it took away from
their championship okay
then you get toronto raptors
championship
kevin durant gets hurt
uh clay thompson gets hurt
boom so that's the one where we go
toronto wouldn't have beat golden state
warriors if they were 100 percent
done
by the way
actually let's go back to the first
golden state warriors championship
san antonio was beating the [ __ ] out of
golden state that year
kawhi leonard got hurt remember when
kawhi leonard got hurt game i believe it
was even game one
he stepped on that dude's
foot they even changed the rule after
that for like when a guy's up in the air
and a dude invades his space he hurts
his ankle
kawhi leonard's out golden state goes on
to win they shouldn't even have been
past san antonio that year
that's the thing
kind of stuff that you kind of go oh
that's weird i know injuries are a part
of the game guys i'm just saying we want
to see the best competition go at each
other so you have that and that right
toronto raptors championship
right
no way we we all know there's no way kd
and klay thompson if they're healthy
they beat the hell out of toronto then
you got the los angeles lakers
championship
this one just has
many asterisks on it okay
one kovit they stopped playing for five
months where this older lebron james and
this injury-prone anthony davis get to
rest for five months and then go into a
small sample playoff run to go into the
championship you know and then they went
on and won the championship
that's
it's a tough championship because i had
to do it in the bubble i'm not taking
anything away from it but there is like
look the lakers have not they can't do
it when they're playing a regular season
they what anthony davis hurt can't play
23 games he's missed or something like
that
lebron james is older he can't carry the
team like he once did so boom there's
that and then you have the milwaukee
bucks championship last year who
are getting their asses handed to them
by 40
with kevin durant and kyrie irving
playing
kyrie goes down
the rest is history milwaukee goes on to
win the championship so i'm saying man
can we get a legit champion this year or
not let me not use the word legit
can we get a competitive
championship game this year where it's
like this team is great that team is
great you know what i'm saying
all right
that's my nba talk
that is all of the nba talk guys now
let's talk about
um this
show that i started watching called
severance
all right
so
that's all that talk so severance
severance severance so this is a show on
apple tv uh many people have asked me to
um
talk about the show i've gotten a lot of
messages about that and by the way
thanks first make sure you subscribe
guys hit that subscribe button right now
and remember that i also i'm on twitch
i'll be on twitch after this so anyways
man severance um this show is wild dude
it's one of these shows that has like a
a a really good concept
you know what i mean you know so it's
like so they they they wrap you in
with the concept of the show you know so
the show um
adam scott plays the lead in the show
that's adam scott right there on the
screen you know so his name's mark and
he leads a team of office workers whose
memories have been surgically divided
between their work
and personal life
when a mysterious colleague appears
outside of work it begins a journey to
discover the truth about their jobs
so at first
i've only watched the first two episodes
there's only three out
um
it's really you know it's one of these
like it ain't your normal show but at
the same time that makes it like a kind
of show where you kind of you you kind
of feel like oh i know where it's going
you don't necessarily know what's going
to happen but you you know it's like
okay so that's happening and your mind
kind of wanders to like what kind of
weirdness is that could possibly go on
so
i'm i'm i'm hooked but i also feel like
uh i think you're trying to be too
clever it's more clever than you know
good right uh but it stars adam scott
zach cherry britt laura
lower and it's directed by ben stiller
you know sort of you know the first
episode you know they're they have to
the first two episodes is they're like
there's no spoilers i'm not gonna give
you any just i'm not gonna spoil
anything for you but the first two
episodes are a lot of like setting up
the world
they need to show you the the home life
and the work life they need to
establish that there's something strange
going on uh you know they need to
establish like here's all the characters
here's how the world works they want to
show you like here's how the outside
world is that who because like in this
universe
severance is a thing you know what i
mean it's a thing that people know
happens
so like you know they're you go to an
office and they're like all right so
give me severance and
so i'm not spoiling anything on the show
but i just want to talk about like if
this were real because in the show the
idea is
when you leave work all your memories of
work
vanish
okay
and now you're like outside in like your
locker room area kind of like oh okay i
don't even know what happened at work
today now i'm going home at like
whatever time it is and now i'm living
my home life
but when you go to work it's as if you
never left
like this person wakes up from the the
severance transfer and now they're like
oh i'm still at work
i don't know if i would like that
imagine if it was like
if it was like
when i'm doing my podcast
you know that's the severance that's
because you become two different people
that's the idea in the show is that
you're actually two different worlds
two different persons because in the
show they talk about it's your audi like
that's what the the term they put on it
like you're it's like you're you're
you're audi
you know
and they talk about that person as a
different person so when you're in work
you know you're you're always at work
this is your work personality so you
don't even know if like
like if you have a family you don't know
if you have kids like you don't know
anything about yourself
you don't know if you had a good night's
sleep last night you don't know if you
were depressed you don't know you know
you're just at work
like
your work self so there's part of it
that's like
you know
there's part of it that's like kind of
kind of like damn that's actually that's
actually interesting
um
let me i'm going to put up a poll
because i want to hear what you guys
have to say
uh
you know what i mean so it's like would
you want that so like if i was doing you
know like i say if i'm doing my podcast
so then it would be like i'm just always
doing my podcast like i would just wake
up and be like oh i'm doing the podcast
again
you know what i mean or like you know so
then like you never have like whatever
the the stress whatever the trials and
tribulations that you have at work you
would never take them home so your home
life is just like you don't work
your home life is just like oh i'm just
enjoying my whole life i'm i'm watering
my plants i'm walking my dog i'm on the
weekends i'm doing weekend [ __ ] and i
don't even know about work oh maybe
there's some report i was supposed to do
there's no stress there's no nothing so
like in the universe you can see that
there's a battle on the outside of being
like don't you know
severance is bad there's people there's
factions of people who think like
severance is bad and then there's people
who are like you know oh maybe you feel
like oh this is great my worlds are
split and i don't have to like combine
them so i don't know i don't know where
i
if i would like that or not i don't know
it's just it feel it's a strange thing
you know it's like like like if if it
were me like when i'm doing comedy
i don't know anything about my personal
life
you know what i mean
would that be bad because you'd be on
the road acting like a monster
but you know what i mean like just like
oh so when i go to work i'm i'm just on
the road doing comedy so this person
like so then like the comedian self
is always traveling
you know what i mean so when i'm
traveling it's like oh i'm i'm just i
just stay traveling i'm i'm always a bag
is packed
like my bag is packed and i'm headed to
the airport that's my audi self and then
when i come back i don't know anything
that happened on the road i don't know
anything about like if the shows were
good i don't have to worry about like oh
the stress of any of that it's just
my self it's just me and my lady and
whatever else you got going on in your
life
it's like would you want to do that
would you want to leave work at home you
know what i mean
right now most of you are saying no
you know there's 32 votes for you know
all together and it's like 62 percent of
you are saying no
so then let me let's then let's let's
talk about the positive side of it for a
second if there is i guess the positive
side is like
you you're not the the stress you're not
there you're not combining the stress at
all
but you know what i think i'd say no to
guys because as i i can't even i can't
even justify it right now
because
you know
you you would wouldn't you want to know
when you're at work like why you're
working
like unless your job was super important
most of the time we're doing our jobs
for the purpose of making our lives
better for our families right
i work hard so i can make sure my girl
is taken care of that she's happy that
we're happy so if you don't have that
motivation why are you working
you know like you would it would need to
be something super important
maybe if you're working at nasa or you
working at you know like like the center
of disease control or you're working
someplace that you're doing something so
meaningful
that you know that's why you're working
but for most people that you know how
would you do that i the the the person
that's at home though that that person i
think that that that's the a side
so for that self the person that's at
work i mean i'm saying at home
that person is like yeah
ah man i don't i don't even know what i
do
i don't know what but but they do know
because because you you you in this
world you consciously know that you're
you're you're severance and
you just know you have to go to work
every day
you know so there is a check-in of like
well you got to go to work
so you do know you work so you would
know where you work you go like like
let's say if it was like nasa you go hey
i'm i work at nasa i just don't know
what happens when i'm there you just you
but then you know but then i guess
that'll suck too because when you want
to know so like if you're like a big
time astronaut scientist
and that was your dream
sometimes you want to be at home like
yeah i did that today huh oh i'm so
close to solving a b and c
and you don't have no knowledge of that
so that might kill you at home too so
overall
it probably it probably sucks
but anyways i will say this it's a
fascinating show to watch and i can't
wait to see like where it goes and how
it plays out but obviously something
weird is going on and we're gonna find
out the truth so that part of it i hope
that they go in a like a crazy direction
that
you they it's a satisfying conclusion a
satisfying reason so i hope they do
you know
i hope they do do that but you know at
this point we
you know
you know we'll we'll see if that's
you know you know where they go with it
you know what i mean because as of right
now i just i just don't know
i don't know but like i say
i will give the show about three and a
half woo-woos
[Music]
so that's how we do that y'all
all right guys
that's about it today
we did it
make sure you subscribe make sure you
share it
again like i said earlier i also
i also am doing um
extra bonus content on patreon so come
to my patreon eric griffin if you want
to be a part of that
if you want to play video games with me
too that's part of being a part of the
patreon and making a week in war zone
together or you can even just go to my
twitch and be a member of my twitch
there if you want to do that but you
know subscribe share
and all that great stuff
and
i hope i satisfied your curiosity about
king and the sting
uh it is what it is so you know i'm sure
i'll be on in a few episodes but just
let them establish what they're doing
because that's the whole purpose of it
they're just trying to establish the new
thing
so give them time to do that but
anyways everybody thanks for watching
with griffin and make sure you share
this like do all that great stuff and i
will
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]